- You should probably think about,
you know, things you enjoy
when it's just you, alone.
- Eww, I don't do that.
- Women do tend to feel more shame
surrounding masturbation than men,
feeling that it is sort of taboo.
- If you want me to go away,
you know what you have to do.
- (sighs) Jerk off.
- Jerk off, yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
Let's go to the bathroom and climax
into that thin toilet paper.
- Unh.
- You're 16, you're not supposed
to know the answers to anything.
- Listen to me, you
wanna shoplift lipstick,
you wanna listen to Lana Del Rey on repeat
while you cut up all your t-shirts,
you wanna scream at your mother
and then laugh at her tears.
- I, just, it's perfectly
normal for a younger man
to be sexually attracted
to a mature woman.
- Just picture your
dad's associate, Susan.
- Oh, Susan, mmm, Susan actually
came to this summer outing
and she said that I was really sprouting
into a fine young man.
- That's right, look at her sinewy arms.
- Susan show me your top naked.
- Yeeeesss.
- Oh, God.
- And she's got fallopian tubes.
- Oh, God, okay,
(squelching)
so Susan, what's it like
to be in human resources (grunting).
- Make a grand gesture.
- What like flowers?
- Grander.
- Like a giant teddy bear?
- Much grander, think like Rom Com grand.
You know, public, passionate,
heart on your sleeve,
running through the rain, if
it seems too much, go bigger.
- (chuckling) Very funny.
- Show her you like her,
kick her in the shin.
- Jesus Christ.
- Rule number one, enthusiasm
is more important than technique.
Yeah, don't go to deep, looks awkward.
You can use a bit more pressure
than you think, actually,
but no teeth, specially if
you're packin' metal, Natalie.
Ennh (humming)
- How else are guys
supposed to get blow jobs?
- You lean your head back,
arch your crotch in the air,
and say, dinner is served.
- I've noticed you're
pretending to masturbate
and I was wondering if you
wanted to talk about it.
- Let's grip it and rip it.
- No, no, no, I don't wanna do this now.
- But you found out Missy's
still into you, pump your stump.
- I think, if she doesn't
want you at her party,
it's important that
you respect her wishes.
- She's a horny spaz,
you should jazz on her.
- Jazz?
- Jizz on a spaz, jazz.
- She's not an object.
- Whoa.
You keep describing her
as inanimate objects,
but she is a person.
Have you even thought about asking her
what she wants, or what she likes?
- I like your fedora.
It evokes jazz's colorful
past and funky future.
- That was the exact vibe
I was trying to summon.
- Yeah, good banter, now tell her
you wanna wear her ass as a hat.
- Oh, really?
- You can't choose who
you're attracted to.
You can't, you can't
engineer a relationship.
You have to do what's right.
- I think what Lola's trying to say
is that you're a total hypocrite.
- Let's fuck 'em both up.
- No.
- Is it working for you?
(water splashing)
- That maybe we should
like rub fronds (groaning).
- Oy a voy.
- Hold on does she wanna dry hump?
- Oh, God.
- You can't pass up the opportunity
to grind your dick against
a rough denim pant.
- Look, I know it feels
like everyone's doing it,
and, yeah, some people are,
but most of us aren't yet.
It's not a race.
- Kiss 'im, kiss him hard on the mouth.
(kissing)
- Oh, my God, I can't believe
this is happening again.
- Shut up and kiss me.
- Now stick your pinky in his
little toffee colored tushy.
- If you're going to do drugs tonight,
remember to buddy up
- Mom.
- and look after one another.
Let me get you some condoms.
- No thanks, mom, bye.
- You don't have a choice,
you're going, end of story.
- No, no, no, no, no.
Hit her, hit her while she's drivin'.
- Shouldn't matter what
anyone in the school thinks.
You are who you are.
Don't let anyone take that away from you.
- I don't really wanna be
friends with the popular girls.
- Of course you do, everybody wants
to be friends with Devon,
she's the queen bee.
And you want that honey, buzz.
- Hey, Devon.
- I know it's hard,
but if you've asked her
and she said no, then I
think you've got your answer.
- Ooh, ooh, ooh, tell
him to send a dick pic.
Girls love that.
- Love isn't about grand gestures
or the moon and the stars,
it's just dumb luck.
And sometimes, you meet
someone who feels the same way.
- Oh, yeah, yes, that's it.
Don't be afraid to lead with your groin,
the world's slowest hula hoop.
- Oh, this is working.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Take it easy, we're 70
yards from the bathroom,
brother, you need to slow it down.
- Ah, no, can't slow
down, can't slow down.
- Fuck it, if you're okay
with it, I'm okay with it.
- I'm okay with it.
(grunting)
- Ji ho.
- Unh.
- Be proud of your penis and your heritage
'cause neither are going anywhere.
You should work with what you got.
- Wait, what do we do about the mess?
- Sleep in it, Pig.
(kissing)
(door clicking shut)